am 24 oktober wird also im neuen
bundestag die eröffnungsrede gehalten
vom alterspräsidenten aber so lange
wollen wir nicht warten hier kommt der
mann der für jede partei eine echte
ziele wäre
herzlich willkommen gernot hassknecht
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren es ist mir eine
große ehre zum ersten mal in diesem
hohen hause zu schmecken
direkt unter dem legendären bundes
freuler im rechten und männlichsten
parlament das wir je hatten selbst bei
der prostata vorsorge trifft man mehr
frauen als hier vorbildlich allerdings
die neu gegründete frauke petry partei
mit einem frauenanteil von nahezu 100
prozent
[Applaus]
selbst grüne und linke die großen
frauenversteher stellen bei den
direktmandaten dann doch lieber männer
auf denn ihr seid zwar grundsätzlich
schon irgendwie für frauen aber selber
viele jahre
neben dem mädchen sitzen nein hier in
der bude soll es weiter nach testosteron
mission nach jungs umkleide nach thun
heute ganz unten jedes mal wenn ihr eine
frau redet denn macht der arrogante
zwischenrufe dieser macho das ist so was
von dem nicht ertragen und traut sich da
seine eier
ich entschuldige mich berührt für den
macho oder früher was jetzt für die eier
trainer grauen geht also ungebremst
weiter
alles wie gehabt neu im bundestag ist
nur die afd
man fragt sich allerdings wie lange noch
diese woche ist schon wieder einer
ausgetreten statt 94 sitze habt ihr
jetzt nur noch 92
zwei abgeordnete in zwei worten wenn ihr
in dem tempo weiter macht hat sich der
verein in 92 wochen also genau am 12
juli 2019 komplett aufgelöst
jetzt nicht nachlassen
[Applaus]
ja man soll die sorgen der af die wähler
ernst nehmen ließ ich jetzt überall
dabei keinen bock 95 prozent von denen
haben zitat angst ihre deutsche kultur
zu verlieren
wer will denn bitte unsere kultur trauen
bisschen mehr selbstbewusstsein auch in
100 jahren wird es noch schützenfeste
geben wo wir nach 14 cola weinbrand der
örtlichen leberwurst königin in den
ausschnitt reihen weil wir deutsche sind
und an alle etablierten parteien hier
berger feld auf der afg nach dem mund zu
reden ich sage jetzt nicht wen ich meine
aber ich weine die csu
[Applaus]
hört auf euch bei diesen popeligen 12,6
prozent einzuschleimen was ich denn mit
den 87,4 prozent die nicht als die
gewählt haben also ich wer schreibt sich
bei mir ein ich war nie gut in mathe
aber nach meiner rechnung sind 87,4
prozent die mehrheit oder in der sprache
der idioten
wir sind das volk
[Applaus]